what are you eating so I'm making my  videos today it's Wednesday afternoon  I'm feeling sick so that's why I'm front  of my laptop copy a little bit I'm  getting better but I'm almost through it  and I want to know what you're eating so  usually i'm eating something healthy on  my video days today here's what I've got  I've got some honey mustard salmon with  broccoli and quinoa I just finished a  whole bunch of tea with honey for my  throat and i'm snacking on some cashews  this is a lot of magnesium in them and i  like them and magnesium is good for the  bones so i want to achieving leave a  comment let me know what you're eating  and that's it give it a thumbs up  subscribe to the channel I'll see you  soon